right this holiday season a new
Christmas comedy is out it's called
Jingle smells it is a fun family movie
it's heartwarming and it also has an
anti-woke message take a look you know
it's very hard to find a place that even
comes close to being worthy of your
beauty it's romantic it's about you and
me alone wow look at the two of you
Merry Christmas America Hollywood has
cancelled Mason stone stone will be
digitally replaced by AI poot Stone we
will no long longer be manufactured
Mason Stone character get them all out
of here by Christmas Eve you got to be
kidding me how'd you get it oh fell off
the truck there was a truck involved the
mysterious Gift Giver has struck again
you get busted with those tools you're
done and you made me an accessory well
you know what they say some accessories
are required am I smiling no jingle
smile jingle smile stinking all the way
they called me jingle
smells yeah I know it's a fun movie yes
obviously I'm in it and one of the ex
itive producers anyway here now is one
of the stars of jingle smells actor John
Schneider uh all right you're amazing in
the movie uh I've always known you're
amazing it was great great to have the
opportunity to be on this project with
you well thank you very much it was so
wonderful to be uh be involved in a
movie that the whole family could watch
you know we used to do Mo Movies in
television like dare I say Dukes of
Hazard like Smallville where people
whether with whether they were four
years old or 94 years old they enjoyed
the same programming and that's what
jingle smells is plus you know having
been probably I would I would say one of
the first groups to be cancelled by
cancel culture you know the dues of
Hazard because of the rebel flag you
know I I am I have been an action figure
that has been canceled so I love doing
this movie I really did thank you for
making it happen so what's interesting
is is something for the kids obviously
something for the parents um it features
is Nick Gutman uh who Ben devies does a
great job playing this role he takes a
job with
your how do you say it let's say
offbeat with what I get him a job in in
the sanitation department because he
doesn't get a job on his own and uh he
finds these discarded toys and gives
them to Children uh for for Christmas
you know and I'm one of the founders of
Children's Miracle Network hospitals so
the fact that this movie takes place in
children's hospitals really speaks well
to me as well so because it's at the end
of his work day you know he smells a
little bit so the kids like we just saw
called him jingle smells and the I I
just think it's wonderful I really do
folks Jingles smells. movie Jingles
smells. movie if you want to get a hold
of something you want you want to buy a
DVD send them on this mission to destroy
you know perfectly good toys by
Christmas Eve they're pulled from the
the
shelves um yes based on you know being
cancelled him being cancelled for his
patriotic views and instead you know he
ends up being the good guy the the the
Robin Hood of the movie so what I love
about it is parents get to see oh uh the
woke world gets defeated and all in the
spirit of Christmas which I really
love absolutely you know and and like on
Dukes of Hazard the good guys get in
trouble for doing the right thing so
this this movie I think will speak to
many many people um and and and like I
said it's something everyone can watch
at the same time and it pokes a finger
in the eye of the woke cult culture
which we need to do Sean we need to do
it I mean it's it's time that we just
said enough is enough don't you think I
I got to tell you I think it's time you
know look there are some movies that are
timeless
and I don't I don't know just just the
whole notion of this and how relevant is
to to today's world um it's interesting
your background your experience what you
bring to the film and there's a hero in
this film and I love that part of it and
uh the fact that it connects to real
life cancel culture makes me even more
happy my entire career people too have
tried to cancel me and I'm like well I'm
still here uh they haven't been
successful yet uh all right so the truth
the truth set you free right the truth
will set you free so so for folks who
are watching this if you're a Dukes of
Hazard fan you're going to love it if
you were a Smallville fan you know this
is kind of Dukes of Hazard true
modern-day Robin hoods meet Jonathan
Kent from Smallville so uh it's a great
opportunity it's a wonderful time to be
able to sit with your family watch a
movie for a change where you can talk
about it after it it is educational but
it doesn't beat you over the head but
it'll give you something to talk about
with your family after afterwards which
I think is entertainment's job really
that's what I think entertainment is
supposed to do well you're great at it
it was uh great to have an opportunity
to work with you uh people looking for
it it's on Rumble the website is what
jingle smells. mov Jingles smells. movie
yeah Jingles smells. mov or you can go
to my website which is John Schneider
studios.com get a DVD check out what we
have at the store uh but I applaud you
for making this movie happen it wouldn't
have happened without you so well it's
my actually it was fun for me to do I
enjoyed every part of it the worst part
of it is me being on screen but the best
part is when you're on screen uh John
schneer great to see you my friend I
hope people will find it jingle smells
well merry Christmas everybody you take
care God bless you byebye Merry
Christmas God bless you my friend hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else